idée de ma candidature plus exactement
c'est de permettre à des à des centaines
de milliers de femmes et d'hommes de
d'exprimer leurs intérêts tout
simplement
mais ce sont des solutions et même ce
sont des solutions essentielles et si on
se bat pas politiquement pour chacun est
un emploi pour qu'on se répartisse le
travail pour éradiquer ce chômage de
masse pourquoi ce bâton nous ah laissez
les belles promesses les beaux parleurs
dans le vide mais la vie de millions de
gens elle est suspendue à ça
les beaux parleurs parler dans le vide
mais quand vous demande une alternative
une solution après si vous parvenez à
atteindre
elle consiste à à ce que les millions de
femmes et d'hommes qui travaillent
aujourd'hui se battent pour que leurs
droits pour que leurs intérêts
effectivement soit enfin respectés enfin
respecté et moi je ne vois pas d'autres
moyens que de le faire au travers d'un
rapport de force parce que la réalité
c'est que des élections on en a eu
beaucoup il y a eu président de la
République des majorités
gouvernementales qui ont changé et ils
ont toujours fait la même politique
posez-vous la question mais parce que
moi
politique et ma politique c'est de dire
ne vous laissez pas abuser ne tombez pas
dans cette durée des élections au dessus
de ses prisons de la République il y a
un pouvoir bien plus puissant